bonsoir à toutes et à tous heureux de
vous retrouver pour une nouvelle semaine
de sens public on est ensemble pour 90
minutes du lundi au jeudi à 18h et 22h
pour donner du sens à l'actualité et
voici le sommaire de ce 16 janvier à J -
3 de la première journée d'action et de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites tout le monde des syndicats du
gouvernement au sondeur en passant par
les syndicats tout le monde s'attend à
une forte mobilisation
tout le monde a bien perçu que cette
mesure elle est injuste donc oui il y a
tous les ingrédients pour que cette
mobilisation soit très très forte
dit aujourd'hui dans dans Le Parisien
soyons un million ce serait bien
je pense qu'on peut on peut être plus
l'appel sera-t-il entendu de la
puissance de ce mécontentement dépendra
la suite du mouvement et la réaction des
uns et des autres on se demandera
comment gagner la bataille de l'opinion
dans une minute et puis c'est un second
thème d'actu que je vous propose ce soir
consacré à la guerre en Ukraine le bilan
effroyable du bombardement d'un immeuble
d'habitation à ni pro les combats à
soledar les Britanniques qui vont livrer
des chars lourds la Russie qui
pourraient mobiliser 500 000 hommes
supplémentaires beaucoup d'événements à
décrypter tout à l'heure avec nos
experts avec cette question centrale
est-ce que le conflit sans Lise
mais d'abord c'est la chronique d'une
manif annoncée que nous raconte Mathias
Arès
syndical appelle de ses vœux secteurs de
l'énergie des transports ou même dans la
fonction publique la mobilisation
s'organise ce week-end l'homme fort de
la CGT Philippe Martinez disait attendre
un million de manifestants dans les rues
avec Philippe Martinez on est d'accord
pour que le 19 soit massif et ensuite on
est d'accord pour regarder comment on va
faire pour les fois suivantes alors
justement que le gouvernement nous
écoute
sanctionne les travailleurs une
opposition frontale à la réforme des
retraites soutenues majoritairement au
lendemain des annonces d'Élisabeth borne
de Français sur 3 se disaient
défavorables à un report de l'âge légal
du côté du gouvernement la mobilisation
passe mal la grève le droit de grève
bien entendu c'est un droit
constitutionnel le droit de manifester
constitutionnel exprimer ses idées bien
entendu mais bloqué non empêcher ceux
qui veulent aller travailler de
travailler non
et nous ferons respecter cette règle
simple pendant cette journée de
mobilisation le premier rôle sera
syndical avant l'entrée des politiques
dans la bataille samedi une marche est
déjà prévue à Paris à l'initiative de la
France insoumise
mobiliser convaincre réformer trois
verbes trois mots clés pour cette
réforme des retraites et donc de cette
bataille de l'opinion qui se prépare en
en débat avec leur Salvin bonsoir
bienvenue directrice générale de cantar
publique parce qu'elle Perrine au
bonsoir bienvenue sur politologue
professeur à Sciences Po Paris
Jean-Marie Pernaut bonsoir bienvenue à
vous aussi politologue chercheur à
l'Institut de recherche économique et
social et votre livre le syndicalisme
d'après publié aux éditions du retour et
Mathieu croissanto éditorialise
politique bonsoir Mathieu bienvenue à
vous leur Salvat on sait que l'opinion
elle est majoritairement défavorable à
cette réforme mais comment elle évolue
est-ce qu'elle est de plus en plus
défavorable au fil des semaines c'est
vrai que depuis que finalement la
réforme devient plus concrète qu'on
connaît les différentes mesures de cette
réforme et bien effectivement on voit
une hostilité de plus en plus franche de
l'opinion à l'égard de cette réforme
alors l'hostilité elle elle se
cristallise je dirais à plusieurs
endroits d'abord il y a la question de
la pertinence de cette réforme est-ce
que c'est le bon moment est-ce que le
système est en danger ou pas et là les
Français ils sont à nouveau une grande
majorité à dire système fonctionne très
bien ils sont pas du tout convaincus
effectivement qu'il y a un problème de
financement en tout cas pas aujourd'hui
donc problème de pertinence de
légitimité et puis aussi problème sur le
fond parce que la mesure que l'on
retient la mesure phare de cette réforme
c'est l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite qui va passer donc à 64 ans a
priori et ça c'est vraiment une mesure
symbolique très forte c'était quelque
part comme un garde-fou pour les
Français en disant voilà on a ces 62 ans
d'âge légal et quand on posait la
question
aux Français ce qu'il préférait est-ce
qu'il préfère qu'on allonge les
cotisations
qu'on touche plutôt
à l'allongement des trimestres etc c'est
toujours plus près plus plus en soutien
que effectivement
le symbole de l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite et je crois que les Français se
focalisent beaucoup et c'est vrai que
toutes les autres mesures elles ont du
mal à passer sur la pénibilité sur
l'emploi des seniors etc finalement
entendre un âge légal parce qu'elle
Perino c'est un phare éblouissant d'une
certaine façon qui met dans l'ombre le
reste de la réforme est-ce que c'est
toute la réforme qui est pour l'instant
rejeté par une majorité de l'opinion non
quand vous regardez les enquêtes vous
apercevez que 64 ans là ça fait mal
mais quand vous regardez en détail en
particulier le volant davantage social
une retraite qui ne pourrait pas être en
dessous de 1200 euros d'autres modalités
relatives à la pénibilité aux exceptions
qui sont déjà prévues par le projet born
à l'application sèche des 43 à nuités
puis ensuite de de l'âge pivot de 64 ans
vous apercevez que là il peut
une opinion fluide sur le sujet
Jean-Marie Pernot si on se projette là
sur la journée de jeudi évidemment on va
être prudent les uns et les autres mais
quels sont les signes qui permettent
d'évaluer la puissance d'une première
journée d'action j'entendais je lisais
juste avant que l'émission de démarre se
communiquer de la CGT qui prévoit au
moins 200 points de rassemblement je dis
dans toute la France il faut pas être
nous journaliste trop focus sur Paris
aussi ça c'est une dimension importante
vous avez tout à fait raison dans les
grands mouvements dans les grandes
séquences protestataires qu'on a déjà
connues en 2010 par exemple qui va
rester quand même le point de référence
parce que on l'a sous-estimé ce
mouvement de 2010 et pour moi le plus
important depuis depuis Mai 68 et
effectivement on pouvait le voir à
travers les points de les points de
rassemblement plus ils sont nombreux
plus ça veut dire syndicats ont quand
même
cette capacité de les organiser après on
verra la fréquentation bien évidemment
c'est un autre enjeu mais je crois que
là ce qui est annoncé est de haut niveau
après des préavis de grève aussi ça peut
permettre il faudrait voir il faudrait
voir plus précisément bon et il est
évident que dans les services publics
que l'on connaît
les préavis de grève ont été déposés
mais comme vous le savez dans le secteur
privé ils sont pas contraints à ce droit
de grève donc à ce droit ce devoir de
préavis cette obligation de préavis donc
là on peut pas trop savoir mais dans les
services publics ils ont été déposés
donc on verra bien je crois que la
question de la grève est un des enjeux
du conflit parce que
va se les propos de Bruno Le Maire le
montre d'ailleurs c'est-à-dire que les
manifestations c'est une des faiblesses
du mouvement de 2010 qui était
essentiellement un mouvement manifestant
mais le support gréviste était
relativement faible et bon on sait
historiquement ça déplaît peut-être
ministre mais les mouvements qui ne
s'appuient pas sur des grèves en général
c'est les mauvais moments à passer mais
on fait le dos rond le patronat ça le
concerne pas c'est ça s'adresse aux
politiques publiques et les
gouvernements ma foi c'est quelques
jours d'un popularité et les choses
reprennent leur cours par contre si la
grève s'installe et qu'elle s'encre
avec les les risques sur l'activité
économique du pays là je pense qu'il y a
d'autres acteurs qui vont se réveiller
notamment le patronat qui est assez
discret dans cette affaire oui parce que
la réforme lui convient plutôt enfin lui
convient mais quand on regarde en tout
cas c'est officiellement c'est ce qui
est assez spécialité mais je pense que
s'il y a des six à dégradent la
situation économique peut-être que les
pressions aussi sur le politique vont se
faire sentir de ce côté-là mais c'est
très juste ce que vous dites parce qu'en
2010 on s'en souvient plus ou moins mais
il y a eu 14 journées de mobilisation
rassemblant jusqu'à 2 millions pour
certaines journées de français en tout
cas à l'époque on estimait c'était pas
les mêmes une fois sur l'eau et c'était
pas les mêmes donc je parle un peu de
l'histoire
ça n'a rien donné pour les manifestants
puisque la loi est passée la loi a été
appliquée je pense qu'on est aussi comme
je dis Pascal Perrineau dans une
bataille de récit aujourd'hui entre le
récit gouvernemental et le récit des
syndicats et des oppositions et pour
l'instant force est de constater quand
on on regarde les sondages et vous les
avez très bien écrit que ceux qui
emportent le récit c'est ceux qui disent
un message assez simple au fond que
cette réforme elle est à la fois inutile
elle est injuste et elle est inefficace
et son les critiques qu'on entend et
ceux qui disent elle est inutile c'est
pas le moment il y a pas besoin vous
entendez François Hollande ce matin qui
dit on a demandé pas dans l'urgence il y
a pas d'urgence à réformer voilà donc
c'est une critique et des injustes ça
c'est un discours qui est porté fort par
les syndicats et ils ont raison sur
certains aspects de la réforme et puis
les inefficaces c'est cette façon ça ne
servira rien puisque faut s'y remettre
dans dans dans 20 ans il faudra refaire
une réforme parce que de toute façon ça
ne suffira pas et tous ces messages ont
été à mes yeux pour l'instant attendu
ils ont davantage infuser dans l'opinion
publique que les messages du
gouvernement pourquoi parce que le
gouvernement a énormément varié sur les
motivations de sa réforme et n'a pas su
emporter en tout cas l'adhésion des
Français parce que c'est compliqué si on
réforme dite punitive mais il a pas su
convaincre en tout cas ni de la
nécessité
de la pertinence du contenu de la
réforme et ni des détails pour chacun
alors il y a la question de de d'un
chiffre qu'on cherche toujours nos
journalistes à un chiffre on l'entendait
dans dans les titres avec ce million de
de personnes mobilisées jeudi alors il y
en a qui qui est prudent c'est le
secrétaire général de la CFDT il se
prononce pas sur la question de du
chiffre qu'il faut qu'il y ait le
maximum de personnes qui participent aux
manifestations partout en France pour
dire clairement que cette réforme elle a
le désaccord de du monde du travail et
des travailleurs du travailleuses donc
après on verra bien j'ai pas annoncé un
chiffre avant que les manifestations ait
lieu mais c'est vrai qu'il faut qu'il y
ait le maximum de personnes dans la rue
pour et de façon pacifique on a la
chance vous savez dans un pays qui a le
droit où on a le droit de dire son
désaccord avec ceux qui gouvernent on a
le droit de manifester etc ne présentons
pas ça comme un problème par tout
ailleurs quand il y a des manifestations
on dit on soutient les peuples qui se
mobilisent alors sur des causes des fois
extrêmement graves et qui sont des
causes démocratiques ou de liberté des
femmes par exemple ne présentons pas ça
comme un problème
alors dans cette première partie de
notre débat autour du mot du verbe
mobiliser il y a cette question
finalement du pouvoir syndical vous avez
commencé un petit peu à déborder à
l'aborder mais leur Salvat est-ce que
les Français se sont petit à petit
éloignés de leur est-ce qu'ils leur font
moins confiance finalement pour pour
peser dans un débat comme celui que l'on
vit actuellement tout à fait c'est vrai
que quand on mesure depuis finalement de
nombreuses années l'opinion on voit que
la confiance à l'égard alors d'une
manière générale des institutions mais
aussi des syndicats elle est en forte
décroissance aujourd'hui vous avez un
petit peu moins d'un Français sur deux
qui font vraiment confiance aux syndicat
pour résoudre les problèmes que se
posent aujourd'hui dans le dans le monde
du travail donc en effet les syndicats
seuls on va avoir du mal à mobiliser je
reviens juste sur le patronage je pense
que quand même le patronat c'est vrai
qu'on l'entend finalement assez peu il
est plutôt soutien mais enfin bon il est
exactement parce que pour le coup je
trouve qu'ils sont extrêmement ils vont
être extrêmement mobilisés notamment sur
l'emploi des seniors parce que avec
cette réforme les Français son devoir
travailler beaucoup plus tard et
aujourd'hui
on constate effectivement qu'il y a un
vrai problème sur
l'utilisation entre guillemets l'utilité
des seniors dans les entreprises et la
place des seniors et les entreprises
françaises sont en retard par rapport à
la moyenne européenne en la matière donc
c'était effectivement un enjeu un enjeu
majeur sur le le poids le pouvoir
syndical Jean-Marie pernoy on a vu juste
avant Noël les les syndicats de la SNCF
être un peu on va dire dépassé par un
mouvement qui était né sur les sur les
réseaux sociaux je crois sur Facebook et
ça de mémoire alors ça nous a semblé
très nouveau est-ce que c'est forcément
nouveau ça ou est-ce que c'est déjà
arrivé de voir des mouvements finalement
hors syndicats prendre un peu la main
oui il y a eu des phases on a eu des
années 80 par exemple afin des années 80
c'est parti aussi d'ailleurs de la SNCF
une coordination en 86 avait pris la
main dans un secteur très syndiqué qu'il
était encore plus à l'époque
qu'aujourd'hui enfin ça reste un secteur
assez syndiqué donc ça peut être
surprenant mais on a en l'occurrence
comme ça il y a eu aussi les grands
mouvements des infirmières à la fin des
années 80 qui était conduite par des
coordinations donc c'est pas tout à fait
nouveau aujourd'hui ça c'est amplifié
par l'existence des réseaux sociaux qui
permettent effectivement de se contacter
très facilement puisque un des rôles des
syndicats c'est de faire le lien entre
les salariés entre les travailleurs et
les travailleurs comme on dit maintenant
à juste titre mais donc les réseaux
sociaux sont des facilitateurs de ces
contacts on voit néanmoins les limites
et je pense que ces mouvements là auront
aussi leurs limites parce que ça marche
bien pour mobiliser il y a aucun
problème pour appeler une grève on l'a
bien vu pour les contrôleurs de train
par contre dès que la direction a fait
des propositions qui supposait
réflexion collective décision est-ce
qu'on continue est-ce qu'on discute
est-ce que ça va est-ce que il y a pas
d'instance d'arbitrage est-ce que vous
faites le parler avec les gilets jaunes
toute proportion gardée c'est justement
sur ce c'est peut-être l'absence de
leadership des mouvements qui pour ce
qui est de la mobilisation
il y a des sociabilités qui se créent
par les réseaux par les
faire connaissance locale ça a été le
cas pour les gilets jaunes les
carrefours qui ont joué ce rôle étrange
mais après il faut il faut que le
mouvement se représente à lui-même il
faut qu'il se donne une représentation
et là-dessus les gilets jaunes ils y
sont jamais parvenus ils avaient
beaucoup de désaccords entre eux etc ils
avaient des points d'accord mais ils ont
eu du mal à choisir des représentants à
trouver quelques idées forces qui les
rassemble tous etc et dans ces
moments-là quand on n'a pas de structure
pérenne pour organiser ses arbitrages
parce que il y a des moments dans la
conduite d'un mouvement il faut arbitrer
et bien c'est un peu la limite de ces
mouvements là si vous voulez donc ils
existent ils sont pertinents pour lancer
les mouvements après on va voir il est
pas exclu que dans le mouvement qui
s'annonce il y a des forces que les
syndicats ne contrôlent pas ça c'est
tout à fait
un peu un test d'ailleurs pour pour les
raisons qui évoquaient madame tout à
l'heure effectivement ils ont perdu
l'emprise sur le social qu'ils avaient
encore il y a une vingtaine d'années
mais c'est pas dit qu'en bout de course
il ne retrouve pas malgré tout leur rôle
d'arbitrage final mais là pour le coup
on est dans du classique
parce que ce sont les confédérations
syndicales en intersection des cas
interprofessionnels qui ont décidé voilà
est fatigué lancent le mouvement et qui
le lance avant les partis politiques
puisque la France insoumise avait une
manifestation prévue deux jours après
sur le silence du Medef c'est aussi
histoire de pas agiter le chiffon rouge
si vous avez Geoffroy route Bézieux et
qui vient dans toutes les matinales dire
qu'elle est géniale cette réforme nous
on va dire c'est vraiment la réforme des
patrons on le repas et de la même façon
d'autres arrière-pensées on a entendu le
gouvernement ce week-end dire oui il y
aura du monde jeudi
c'est ça va être une grosse mobilisation
tout ça pour faire monter aussi la jauge
parce que pourquoi Laurent Berger du
pachiche parce qu'il a pas envie d'être
démenti par les faits donc plus vous
dites on va faire un million 2 millions
3 millions oui il y aura du monde ça
permet éventuellement si la mobilisation
était un peu en deçà de dire vous voyez
c'est une déception Pascal Perrineau je
reviens sur ce parallèle
mouvement un peu hors syndicat et
émouvant gilet jaune c'est alors ça peut
être un une faiblesse du mouvement si ça
prend cette forme là même si
effectivement Mathieu on est d'accord là
je me projette plutôt à l'avenir mais
c'est aussi pour un gouvernement
plus compliqué quoi c'est à dire que de
négocier avec des syndicats entre
guillemets à l'ancienne voilà on l'a vu
au moment d'ailleurs des gilets jaunes
ça a duré des semaines et des semaines
avec un gouvernement qui ne savait pas
et d'ailleurs juste titre avec qui
parler puisque les gilets jaunes
n'étaient pas d'accord entre eux et les
gilets jaunes refusaient même la notion
de représentation il ne voulait surtout
pas de représentants dès qu'il y en
avait un il lui coupait la tête donc là
ça pose un problème énorme et on le voit
depuis les coordinations en effet des
années 80 je me souviens d'un ministre
de l'éducation nationale qui était
confronté aux coordination étudiantes il
disait c'est terrible parce qu'un soir
de manif je me mets d'accord dans la
nuit avec les représentants de la manif
puis le lendemain il y a une autre manif
et les coordinateurs les coordinations
ne sont plus les mêmes donc voilà
comment organiser comme on dit le
dialogue social quand vous n'avez pas de
de représentants mais sur bon pour
l'instant on a des représentants les
représentants un mouvement syndical
univers combien de temps l'unité dure
parce que quand vous regardez en travail
les la conception même de la réforme des
retraites ou du maintien du statu quo
n'est pas le même chez les différents
acteurs syndicaux et puis je vais dire
il va y avoir deux lieux il y a la rue
mais il y a pas que la rue il va y avoir
le Parlement et d'ailleurs ce qui est
très frappant dans les forces qui
s'opposent à la réforme des retraites et
en particulier je pense au rassemblement
national et à Marine Le Pen elle elle
privilégie la scène parlementaire elle
va s'efforcer d'obtenir une évolution du
projet au Parlement à l'Assemblée
nationale en disant d'ailleurs à ces
militants ou à ses adhérents si vous
voulez aller manifester allez-y mais
enfin nous pour nous c'est pas le
problème on voit que la gauche est plus
mouvementiste si vous voulez et sur une
un lieu de contestation qui est un lieu
différent mais il va se passer des
choses à l'Assemblée nationale les
madame borne a un projet extrêmement
précis un projet extrêmement précis pour
l'instant mais elle que le projet peut
encore évoluer donc il y aura des marges
de négociations et il y a un élément
qu'on n'a pas encore abordé c'est l'état
de l'opinion sur la près là c'est
frappant contrairement à ce qui s'était
passé dans les années antérieures vous
avez une opinion qui soutient le
mouvement qui est opposé aux 64 ans ou
43 à nuités mais qui dit toute façon la
réforme elle s'appliquera
ce problème de résignation de l'Union et
est tout à fait frappant et doit être
interprété interpréter vous le ressentez
fortement je trouve que justement c'est
un des éléments qui est très marquant
dans dans cette période actuelle c'est
qu'effectivement d'abord le premier
opposant au gouvernement selon les
Français c'est le rassemblement national
et le rassemblement national qui ne sera
pas a priori en tout cas officiellement
dans la rue déjà sinon ça dit quelque
chose deuxième point c'est quand on leur
demande est-ce que vous souhaitez que
cette réforme est lieu non est-ce que
vous pensez qu'elle va
y compris malgré des mouvements sociaux
etc une grande majorité disent oui de
toute façon elle va être appliquée donc
moi je sais pas c'est de la résignation
de la lassitude de défiance vis-à-vis du
pouvoir syndical ce qu'on évoqué aussi
à l'opposition et au syndicats
finalement à mener le combat jusqu'au
bout et puis surtout par rapport à la
détermination du gouvernement du
président de la République et du et de
la première mise qui paraissent
extrêmement justement déterminée donc ça
c'est vrai que c'est assez inédit comme
comme situation et notamment avec ce
positionnement du RN considéré comme le
premier opposant qui lui ne joue pas
dans la même arène c'est quand même
assez alors Pascal Perrineau vous
parliez évidemment de l'enjeu politique
parlementaire Mathieu ce qui est
intéressant quand on regarde un peu dans
le rétroviseur sur cette réforme des
retraites alors on assiste à beaucoup de
revirements
le projet détaillé du gouvernement et
depuis une semaine le débat fait rage
entre l'exécutif et l'opposition et les
syndicats et
du côté de l'opposition si on met à part
les républicains qui du coup sont dans
une forme d'accord avec le gouvernement
va être tous reproche à l'exécutif une
réforme je disais tout à l'heure inutile
inefficace injuste et parmi les
critiques récurrentes le manque de débat
sur le pourquoi et le comment de la
réforme ça c'est vrai il y a pas eu
assez de débats sur pourquoi on l'a fait
ni comment on l'a fait et un autre angle
d'attaque qui fait fureur c'est les
revirements d'Emmanuel Macron sur le
sujet alors de fait sa réforme des
retraites ne ressemblant rien à celle
qu'il avait promise en 2017 et ce qu'il
a tenté en vain de mettre en place dans
ce premier quinquennat et surtout une
petite phrase qui tourne en boucle sur
les réseaux sociaux elle a été prononcée
par le Président de la République lors
d'une conférence de presse c'était le 25
avril 2019 regardez est-ce qu'il faut
reculer là je les garde qui est
aujourd'hui à 62 ans
je ne crois pas c'est que tant qu'on n'a
pas réglé le problème du chômage dans
notre pays franchement ce serait assez
hypocrite de décaler l'âge légal je veux
dire quand aujourd'hui on est peu
qualifié quand on vit dans une région
qui est en difficulté industrielle quand
on est soi-même en difficulté qu'on a
une carrière fracturée bon courage déjà
pour arriver à 62 ans c'est ça la
réalité de notre pays alors on va dire
NON NON faut maintenant aller à 64 ans
vous savez déjà plus comment faire après
55 ans les gens vous disent les emplois
c'est plus bon pour vous c'est ça la
réalité c'est le combat qu'on mène on
doit d'abord gagner ce combat avant
d'aller expliquer aux gens mais bons
amis travailler plus longtemps c'est le
délai légal ce serait hypocrite
alors c'est sûr que ce genre d'archives
ça fait mal aujourd'hui ça pique ça
pique pas au présent d'autant que le
président n'a jamais vraiment expliqué
on peut changer la vie en politique mais
il a jamais vraiment expliqué pourquoi
il avait changé la vie qu'elles étaient
les raisons de son revirement ou plutôt
même les raisons de la réforme ont
varier avec le temps on a il fallait
sauver le système il fallait dégager des
marches pour faire autre chose les
arguments on varier et pourtant je me
dis que l'opposition serait mieux
inspirée que d'en faire des caisses sur
ce virage à 180° du président parce que
le président est pas le seul à avoir
évolué c'est exactement parce qu'ils ont
presque tous changé d'avis je dis
presque parce qu'il faut reconnaître une
forme de Constance à la France insoumise
qui prône le retour aux 60 ans avec 40
nuts depuis 2012 mais les autres tous
les autres prenez les républicains par
exemple qui fait gagner de trouver le
projet de réforme trop dur trop brutale
et seulement six mois il proposait la
retraite à 65 ans et le programme de la
libraires dans le programme de
législative à l'extrême droite prenez
Marine Le Pen elle s'oppose à la réforme
qui Emmanuel Macron a défendu dans sa
campagne c'était même un clivage assez
net entre les deux candidats mais
elle-même a changé d'avis sur la
question prenez la retraite à 60 ans
pour tous en 2017 d'ailleurs s'est fait
tacler là-dessus et pense qu'elle a
perdu en crédibilité économique
là-dessus et elle a changé le sentir
maintenant au 62 ans sauf pour ceux qui
ont commencé à travailler avant 20 ans
et alors que dire des socialistes
Tartuffe en chef après avoir défendu le
programme de leur candidate Anne Hidalgo
qui elle défendait le maintien à 62 ans
de l'âge légal ils ont signé l'accord de
la nupesse qui lui prévoit comme les
insoumis de revenir à 60 ans avec 40
annuités s'il vous plaît alors que
lorsqu'ils étaient au pouvoir c'est
socialiste qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait une
réforme qui porte le nombre d'annuité à
43 la fameuse réforme Touraine donc là
on est quand même dans le dans le
n'importe quoi et puis j'aurais pu
ajouter les écologistes mais alors là
comme le programme de Yannick Jadot
était famélique sur sur les retraites et
elliptique la seule mention c'était
notre reporterons pas l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite bon quand vous avez
dit ça voilà mais eux aussi ont signé
l'accord de la nupesse et puis elle est
à finit avec une mention spéciale
dédicace à François Bayrou
jamais avoir de conseils on l'a vu
depuis six mois qui s'est fendu d'une
note pour défendre la retraite à 64 ans
ou 64,2 ans selon les scénarios mais
vous savez à combien nous la proposer en
2012 la retraite lui à 65 ans
de regarder un peu les les archives
Jean-Marie Pernaut pour ces formations
globalement le l'enjeu finalement de ce
cette bataille la de l'opinion de cette
réforme des retraites
c'est quoi c'est peut-être l'électorat
populaire comment vous l'analysez ça les
formations politiques quand vous
regardez au-delà des sondages massifs
60% etc quand on regarde par PCs par
catégorie socioprofessionnelle on voit
quand même qu'il y a un écart
considérable dans la vis-à-vis de cette
réforme c'est à dire que dans les
catégories ouvriers employées le rejet
est beaucoup plus massif
et ces catégories là on sait pour qui
elle vote elle vote d'un côté pour la
gauche de l'autre pour l'extrême droite
un des problèmes de de la Major enfin
pour faire vite il faudrait nuancer mais
enfin en gros dans les grandes masses et
ça donc effectivement il y a une dispute
mais ça date pas de d'hier entre entre
le rassemblement national et les forces
de gauche appelons les comme ça pour
faire vite aussi sur la reconquête enfin
ou la conquête ou la reconquête parce
que de la gauche de ces catégories
populaires parce que
deux stratégies très différentes vous
l'avez tout à fait stratégie Marine Le
Pen
parlementaire c'est pour ça que c'est
pour ça que nous vivons
ultra-offensive c'est pour ça que nous
vivons une période passionnante parce
que là il va se jouer énormément de
choses difficilement prévisible moi je
dois dire que je ne sais pas alors sur
la journée du 19 je pense qu'il faut
être prudent aussi parce que ces
mouvements s'apprécient non pas sur une
date mais sur une séquence et même des
fois je rappelle que le CPE les
premières manifestations contre le CPE
étaient chétif donc on aurait on aurait
sans doute fait un pronostic d'échec et
bon
ça s'est arrêté quand ça devenait plus
contrôlable donc on verra je crois
j'accorde pas enfin c'est important la
journée du 19 mais elle ne clôt pas le
cycle ne fait couvrir ainsi donc on
verra bien mais il y a plein d'inconnu
et je pense que c'est une période
d'intense politisation ces mouvements
sur les retraites parce qu'on pourrait
dire une politisation de masse
c'est-à-dire que les gens s'interrogent
sur leur travail parce qu'au fond on
peut pas poser la question des retraites
sans la poser sans poser la question du
travail pourquoi les gens veulent pas
continuer à travailler comme ça plus
longtemps ça renvoie pourquoi la
question des retraites chez nous à une
sensibilité plus forte que dans les pays
scandinaves par exemple mais dans les
pays scandinaves on sait bien qu'après
55 ans les postes de travail sont
adaptés parce que on met pas les gens
dehors parce que bon et donc d'une
certaine manière débat sur les retraites
c'est l'envers du débat qui n'a pas lieu
sur le travail et donc
c'est une période où les représentations
peuvent bouger je sais pas si les
sondages pour les apprécier parce que
tout dépend les questions qu'on pose
aussi mais je pense que c'est une
période qui va avoir une incidence très
très forte sur la suite sur la question
le rassemblement national joue gros sur
cette affaire parce que s'ils sont à
côté du sentiment des gens parce
qu'elles Perrino a rappelé que vous vous
a été rappelé que Marie Le Pen avait
beaucoup changé de position quand même
sur les retraites c'est moins qu'on
puisse dire donc tout ça va se jouer
dans cette période et je pense que les
représentations sont fluides alors ça le
vin ou bien oui parce qu'en fait parler
de politisation c'est très intéressant
aussi quand on regarde l'intérêt pour la
politique chez les Français elle n'a pas
bougé parce qu'elle est toujours à un
niveau très élevé depuis la campagne
présidentielle habituellement après une
campagne présidentielle l'intérêt pour
la politique et l'actualité politique
redescend un peu voilà puis après
remonte en fonction des événements là
elle a à peine un tout petit peu baissé
en novembre et puis elle l'a elle est
remontée en janvier au niveau de la
campagne présidentielle donc
effectivement je pense que les Français
aussi sont très intéressé par les
questions politiques aujourd'hui et
politiques de politiques publiques au
sens noble effectivement du terme et
c'est pour ça que c'est passionnant
aussi parce qu'en fait on est en pleine
recomposition et là où notamment les
Français demandaient beaucoup plus de
compromis de méthodes différentes de la
part du gouvernement etc il y a
peut-être eu justement un petit écueil
là c'est un peu dommage parce que
c'était la grande réforme
des retraits de la première grande
réforme de ce quinquennat et finalement
notamment ne serait-ce que sur les 65
ans peut-être que finalement si 65 ans
avait été annoncé plutôt que 64 et qu'au
final on avait reculé à 64 ans ben déjà
il y aurait eu cette idée de compromis
là je sais pas trop sur quoi on va
pouvoir faire des des compromis toujours
dans l'analyse politique parce qu'elle
Perino bon il y a un allié qui est le
parti LR sauf que il pèse beaucoup moins
dans l'opinion donc est-ce qu'on peut
parler d'un allié affaibli
on peut pas répondre à cette question on
peut pas répondre à cette question bon
l'Allier est décisif l'Allier est
décisif l'attitude du groupe LR c'est
décisif parce que on est passé sans s'en
rendre compte d'une cinquième république
présidentielle à une cinquième
république parlementaire avec cette
affaire de majorité relative pour pour
les forces qui soutiennent le président
de la République donc ils ont besoin de
LR LR joue gros parce que elle est c'est
redonné un patron sur XII
LR s'est encore une réalité au plan
local ça n'est plus grand chose au plan
national moins de 5% des suffrages
exprimés LR c'est une droite de
gouvernement et donc le problème c'est
que LR doit retrouver cette image d'une
force de gouvernement et là d'une
certaine manière ce qui n'est pas facile
en disant on fait un pas
avec la majorité parce que au fond cette
réforme correspond à ce qu'on appelle
peu au prout de nos vœux mais sur le
reste il faudra nous compter dans
l'opposition et d'ailleurs j'ai remarqué
que le PS qui est un peu devant le même
défi comment on devient un grand parti
de gouvernement sur l'enjeu écologique
fait exactement adopte exactement la
même attitude qu'elle est sur son
terrain quelle écologie on va pas leur
demander de faire ça sans les retraites
surtout étant donné les positions 60 ans
40 ans d'annuler 45 unités ça bon ils
sont il y a même une espèce de
régression de la part du Parti
socialiste qui est absolument
hallucinante mais je crois que là et
l'air joue gros
ça peut lui rapporter
une image du gouvernement ça ne va pas
forcément le plombé en disant voilà
c'est devenu les supplétifs de la
République en marche je ne crois pas
alors il y a un mot qu'on entend à
longueur d'interview
des représentants du gouvernement ou de
la majorité présidentielle c'est le mot
convaincre on a on a choisi un petit
échantillon avec Elizabeth borde aurait
berger et François Patriat regardez bien
conscience que faire évoluer notre
système de retraite
suscite des interrogations et des
craintes chez des Français nous voulons
y répondre et convaincre nous on
souhaite évidemment mener cette bataille
de l'opinion publique d'abord au plus
près des Français et j'ai demandé ce
matin aussi que les membres du
gouvernement se mettaient à la
disposition des parlementaires pour
venir sur le terrain expliquer la
réforme se confronter aux Français et
animer aussi eux-mêmes un certain nombre
de réunions publiques il y a des gens
qui ont voté avec nous demain il
convaincre de la justice du combat que
nous menons de la justice du texte
auquel nous aboutons aujourd'hui que
c'est une loi non pas de contrainte mais
de progrès alors qu'on va croire on va
on aurait pu multiplier par deux par
trois par quatre des extraits de
personnalités de la majorité
présidentielle Jean-Marie Pernaut il y a
quand même un élément qui est
intéressant c'est que il y a ce mot
qu'on vaincre donc l'idée qu'on peut
encore discuter éventuellement négocier
que ce soit avec les syndicats ou alors
effectivement au Parlement et puis à
côté de ça il y a l'image de ce
gouvernement avec la succession des 49-3
depuis depuis qu'il est en place donc ça
se ça semble un peu
contre-intuitif enfin paradoxal vous
voyez ce que je veux dire oui bah c'est
un des c'est un des problèmes c'était
vrai qu'on a un régime présidentiel
tempéré désormais heureusement qu'il y a
l'usage du 49-3 qui permet parfois de de
s'affranchir d'une majorité
parlementaire mais je pense que est-ce
que ça donne l'opinion vous devez le
percevoir dans aussi dans les sondages
je crois il y a un peu la part aussi
qu'il y a dans soi-disant résignation
qui est Macron il recule sur rien
que je crois dans son bloc-notes qui
disait la pôle Monsieur Daniel nous dit
que sa politique est un bloc c'est vrai
nous sommes de sous donc là on a un
petit peu ce on a un petit peu ce
sentiment aussi donc un certain
scepticisme sur la capacité à faire
bouger les choses bon après après il
faudra bien tout dépend comment comment
les choses vont évoluer dans le pays je
pense qu'il est possible que le pouvoir
politique bouge mais je parlerai pas
tellement de parce que il y a toujours
une instance de rappel si vous voulez
malgré tout c'est les urnes c'est à dire
que cette résignation fasse un mouvement
social il peut y avoir aussi cette idée
et ça se paiera dans les urnes parce
qu'aujourd'hui on peut plus trop le
faire payer ailleurs c'est vrai
d'ailleurs qu'il y a une tendance quand
même qu'il faut relever qu'on la
retrouve à la SNCF ou ailleurs c'est que
il y a quand même une certaine habitude
notamment des gouvernements
qui est que la protestation sociale
franchement on s'en fout excusez-moi
cette cette familiarité mais enfin Alain
Juppé en 95 il dit moi s'il y a 2
millions de personnes dans la rue mon
gouvernement est foutu vous entendrez
personne aujourd'hui dire s'il y en a 2
millions je dis je suis foutu c'est sous
Sarkozy on a quand même eu voulu évoquer
tout à l'heure 2 millions il y a eu un
brassage de 3 à 4 millions de Français
qui ont participé aux manifestations en
2010 dans les petites îles bretonnes où
il y a 300 habitants il y avait à chaque
fois qu'il y avait une journée d'action
il y avait une manifeste 50 60 personnes
mais dans tous les bars tout le monde
parlait de ça et c'est ça je veux dire
la politisation c'est quand tout le
monde s'intéresse aux choses qui les
concernent et face à tout ça qui a eu un
mur d'indifférence assez total donc
c'est vrai que c'est quand même problème
dans la régulation des sociétés
complexes comme les nôtres que on est on
a l'impression que les gouvernements
sont plus sensibles à l'opinion des
marchés financiers ou des institutions
internationales Cassel qui remonte de
leur population je pense que c'est un
problème de gouvernance comme on dit
aujourd'hui Mathieu un mot et ensuite on
replon c'est que les Français n'ont pas
été pris par surprise entre guillemets
on peut questionner la légitimité cette
réforme mais il avait été annoncé par le
président de la République en campagne
elle a fait débat pendant la campagne
suffisamment puisque tout la plupart des
autres candidats lui sont tombés dessus
ils ont 65 ans c'est fou ça lui a fait
sans doute perdre des points mais il a
ressorti en tête au premier tour il
était élu au second par la suite non
mais il a quand même arrivé en tête au
premier tour et lui au second ensuite il
y a eu la campagne législatives ou cette
question était remise sur le tapis et
celui-là sans doute coûté des voix et un
nombre de députés mais il est arrivé
avec le premier groupe de députés pas la
majorité absolue mais le premier groupe
à l'Assemblée nationale donc c'est pas
non plus quelque chose qui est tombé
dessus on faisait allusion à Juppé les
ordans Juppé quand on en parle enfin la
réforme Juppé les Français la découvrent
ils avaient voté pour Jacques Chirac
voilà avec la social et ils découvrent
Juvet là c'était quand même dans le
programme parce que c'est le début de la
chronique de Steve Jourdain style vous
pouvez nous rejoindre heureusement que
je suis là parce que sinon
plus rien à dire mais ce serait dommage
parce que vous allez effectivement
revenir pour commencer on fait un retour
en arrière vers les précédentes réforme
de retraite sur 1985
Jacques Chirac était du président sur
une promesse on s'en rappelle réduire la
fracture sociale et pourtant et pourtant
quelques mois plus tard Alain Juppé son
premier ministre présente un projet de
réforme de la Sécurité sociale et des
retraites le plan Juppé consiste à
aligner les retraites des fonctionnaires
sur celle du privé qui sont moins
avantageuses on va alors assister à la
plus importante mobilisation du PIB mai
68 le mouvement commence fin novembre il
va durer 23 jours des grèves à la SNCF
et elle arrête à RATP je vais arriver
paralyse le pays les syndicats Paris
viennent à faire descendre 2 millions de
personnes dans la rue et point important
Thomas une large majorité des Français
approuvent le mouvement résultat
Alain Juppé est contraint de reculer au
mois de décembre il retire sa réforme
des retraites alors on a on avance dans
le temps les mobilisations qui vont
suivre ne vont pas avoir autant de
succès en 2003 par exemple François
Fillon et ministre des affaires sociales
du gouvernement Raffin il annonce une
réforme qui prévoit la hausse
progressive de la durée de cotisation un
front syndical si oppose près de 2
millions de personnes descendant la rue
des grèves sont déclarées dans la
fonction publique mais la loi sera quand
même adoptée le 24 juillet 2003 autre
mobilisation contre les retraites elle a
lieu en 2010 la réforme promise par
Nicolas Sarkozy est porté par Eric verdt
les ministres du travail prévoit de
relever l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite de 60 à 62 ans écoutez François
Fillon Premier ministre de l'époque il
est alors en plein bras de fer avec un
certain Bernard Thibault pour sécuriser
notre régime de retraite par répartition
il n'y a qu'une seule solution c'est
celle de l'allongement de la durée de
travail et de l'allongement à 62 ans de
la date à laquelle on prend sa retraite
c'est inimaginable dans un pays où le
taux de chômage des jeunes et des plus
de 50 ans et particulièrement élevé
parmi les plus élevés en Europe donc il
y a au-delà du nez iniquité
des réponses qui ne sont pas des
réponses durables pour assurer une
pérennité du système de retraite par
répartition et malgré plus d'un million
de personnes dans la rue et 14 journées
de manifestations la loi et finalement
adopter le 9 novembre 2010 alors il y a
les réformes des retraites adoptées et
puis à les réformes avortées il a toute
dernière celle présentée par Edouard
Philippe l'idée était de passer un
système universel par point mais le
gouvernement se heurte au refus des
syndicats et des organisations
étudiantes à la RATP à la SNCF une grève
reconductible et lancée le mouvement
dure même 49 jours consécutifs à la RATP
ce qui en fait le mouvement le plus long
de de l'entreprise les manifestations
rassemblent quand elles environ un
million de personnes c'est tout
simplement la plus forte mobilisation
sociale du quinquennat à Macron mais ce
qui va faire dérailler la réforme celle
covid malgré son adoption par
l'Assemblée nationale Emmanuel Macron
annoncement son projet au mois de mars
2021 merci beaucoup Steve Jourdain pour
toutes ces explications il y a on a
commencé à l'aborder je voudrais qu'on
termine là-dessus Pascal Perrineau ce
qui se joue aussi c'est quand même et je
termine par mon troisième bien le verbe
réformer la capacité d'Emmanuel Macron à
réformer ou à donner le sentiment qui
peut encore réformer le pays c'est ça ce
qui se joue parce que sinon bah
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire de la bien sûr
ce second cas c'était le président
souvenez-vous 2017 c'était le président
de la réforme et il a voulu d'ailleurs
garder en partie cette image lors de la
dernière élection présidentielle et
c'est vrai que pour parfois de bonnes
raisons il n'a pas trouvé les espaces
pour désormais on vient de parler en
effet de la réforme des retraites avant
le covid mais qui étaient tout à fait
particulières parce qu'au fond les
réformes de retraite dont on parle c'est
des réformes de paramétrages on joue il
y a jamais eu une grande réforme comme
on dit systémique or Macron était
porteur d'une grande réforme systémique
passée à un système à points et là voilà
la mobilisation partielle le covid ont
eu raison de cette volonté et au fond là
on a une réforme j'allais dire à basse
intensité parce que c'est une réforme
qui ressemble à toutes les réformes
précédentes mais oui on entendait
François Fillon
faudra s'y remettre et c'est un jour des
paramètres qui déclenche la mobilisation
bien sûr donc voyez là on est
d'ailleurs le président se tait regardé
c'est Elisabeth borne qui monte au
créneau elle a l'habitude de ses
dossiers là elle a une sur le sujet et
lui se tait parce que quelque part dans
son fort intérieur s'il a une cohérence
c'est parfois difficile à dire après ce
qu'on a vu tout à l'heure mais si il a
une cohérence il doit se sentir un peu
déçu c'est l'échec de la grande réforme
systémique des retraites en France
Jean-Marie Pernaut sia intervenir
allez-y
une des raisons de la résignation des
Français aussi c'est de se dire bon ben
en fait ce genre de réforme là on les
connaît il y en a eu plusieurs dans le
passé donc quelque part on est beaucoup
moins déjà au surpris aussi par rapport
à ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
c'était annoncé et puis bon bah ah oui
encore une réforme comme ça
effectivement
on va encore remettre en cause le
système alors on est prudent sur ce
plateau et on va continuer de l'être on
verra bien ce que nous ce que nous
réserve les prochains jours les
prochaines semaines mais il y a dans
notre équation il y a quand même un
élément je voudrais bien vous entendre
là-dessus Jean-Marie Pernaut c'est à la
fin mars qu'on connaîtra celui ou celle
qui succédera à Philippe Martinez à la
tête de la CGT est-ce que ça a forcément
ou pas d'ailleurs des conséquences sur
la stratégie des des différentes
branches de ce syndicat la CGT pétrole
transport etc etc là sur ce dossier là
je crois pas parce que c'est un des
sujets sur lesquels il y a une relative
homogénéité de la CGT il y a d'autres il
y a d'autres sur les contrées le plus
musclé on a un petit peu vu au moment de
Total là il y avait sûrement des enjeux
tactiques de cet ordre il y en a un
petit peu toujours mais là en
l'occurrence sur ce sujet là je pense
pas qu'il y ait de qui est dangereux
interne ou que ça bouge en quoi que ce
soit les curseurs compliqués que que la
CGT va gérer au moment de son congrès à
mon avis bon ça va plutôt même redonner
un peu d'allant parce que la cgdm bien
c'est ces périodes un peu de lutte ou
qui reçoivent qui ressoudent un peu
l'organisation justement mais sur la
résignation je serai extrêmement prudent
parce que c'est vrai sur les retraites
ce que vous dites mais en même temps et
ça je trouve qu'on apprécie pas et on
peut pas trop l'apprécier à travers les
sondage parce que c'est c'est difficile
d'aller chercher ça mais c'est aussi
qu'on est en pleine période d'inflation
on est en pleine période où il y a
énormément de français pouvez même
d'ailleurs qui ont un souci avec les
avec la prolongation de la durée du
travail qui ont des problèmes de fin de
mois je suis désolé de on dit que
l'inflation est à 6% le caddie moyen il
a fait plus qu'un pourcent il y a des
gens n'oubliez pas quand même la médiane
du salaire c'est 1700 euros ça laisse
voir le nombre de ménages qui
aujourd'hui ont des problèmes
dramatiques pour boucler leurs fins de
mois et ça la faire des retraites arrive
en plus à ce moment-là et je sais pas
trop ce que ce mélange peut donner parce
que ça peut être mobilisateur évidemment
mais démobilisateur aussi parce que
Mathieu le disait la semaine dernière ça
coûte ça coûte cher ah c'est ceux qui
font grève aussi absolument donc on ne
sait pas on ne sait pas on peut terminer
la voiture moi j'aime bien cette
prudence collective avant un mouvement
social parce que voilà on aura beaucoup
d'autres émissions et beaucoup d'autres
débats pour le suivre évidemment et vous
informer sur l'avancée des
manifestations des discussions
éventuelles et des débats au Parlement
merci à tous encore une fois Jean-Marie
je rappelle le titre de votre livre
syndicalisme d'après qui est publié aux
éditions du retour